[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
imagine living on the moon you'd have
the best view of Earth you'd enjoy
bouncing around in zero gravity and
living your life as an astronaut
explorer doesn't that sound nice except
living on the moon won't be like this at
all
so what would it be like to actually
live on the moon who will establish a
base first and why would moon dust be
your biggest problem this is what if and
here's what would happen if we settled
on the moon let's make this clear
just like America did in 1969 humans
will land on the moon again in the next
decade only this time it's expected to
be more permanent what's less clear is
exactly which country will be the first
to land and establish a base China the
USA Russia and India are all making
strong efforts to get there but there
are also private companies including
SpaceX and Blue Origin that have a lot
more money to spend on going to the moon
but wait why exactly are these companies
doing this in the first place apart from
exploring the galaxy and breaking new
ground there's another huge reason these
groups all want to be the first to
create a base on the moon and that
reason is money
the moon is chock-full of different
resources it has gold silver and
titanium in it the idea here is to mine
these precious resources and send them
back to earth another resource the moon
has is helium-3 it's incredibly rare
here on earth but not on the moon that's
because the moon doesn't have an
atmosphere and helium-3 comes from the
sun's radiation over billions of years
the moon has been absorbing this
chemical and lucky for us it can be used
for energy helium-3 is so powerful that
just 100 kilograms of it could power the
city of Dallas Texas for an entire year
oh and it's also worth a cool forty
thousand dollars for just 28 grams of
the stuff with these resources holding
incredible values it's no secret these
countries and companies want to be the
first to establish a base but even if
they do they won't really own it back in
1967 the United Nations decided that no
one can really own space this has the
potential to cause huge tensions between
various nations possibly leading to war
but enough about all that drama you are
on the moon so how exactly are you going
to live here assuming we get to the moon
in one piece which is already an
incredibly difficult task on its own
you'll then have to worry about
establishing a base experts suggest that
we live on the moon's South Pole as it
gets the most consistent amount of
sunlight there are also massive fields
of ice that we'll be able to harvest
some other places on the moon don't get
any sunlight for nearly a month at a
time luckily you'll have robots to help
you establish a base there are many
different ways they'll be able to help
one includes using moon soil to
construct bricks and configuring them in
a dome-like fashion sort of like a moon
glue this would make traveling to the
moon a lot cheaper as we wouldn't have
to bring everything from Earth to make
our base but don't
affect this base to be glamorous it'll
most likely be several meters
underground to protect you from the
sun's radiation and as for what you'll
eat well it'll be your standard dry
astronaut food the good news is that you
should be able to grow some carrots and
tomatoes a 2014 Dutch study found that
it's possible using soil on the moon and
what would you drink unfortunately quite
a lot of it will be your recycled pee as
drinking water won't be available on the
moon and it would be too heavy to ship
there another thing you'll need to
seriously worried about is moon dust
this magnetic dust gets everywhere it'll
get on your suit and even on your skin
previous astronauts have had allergic
reactions to it it's also slightly sharp
so accidentally swallowing any would be
a huge problem but it's not just humans
who need to worry about moon dust it can
get into machines as well causing them
to overheat before we settle on the moon
this is one massive problem we'll need
to solve all these issues beg the
question would you ever really want to
be the first to settle on the moon you'd
most likely spend your time mining and
just surviving with little time to run
around in low gravity and besides we all
know that going here is just our first
baby step to get to Mars so maybe you
should just wait for that that sounds
like a story for another what if